we all we have okay good so welcome
everybody to the the second session
today and in this session we'll see some
really cool applications the build on a
lattice techniques instead of boring
from the obfuscation constructions the
first day the talk is going to be
bye-bye venket to tell us about lockable
obfuscation thanks Anja ah
can everyone hear me I take that as a
yes
okay hello everyone good morning good
afternoon good evening depending on your
time zone so this is going to be yet
another confiscation
we've already had by wonderful talks and
obfuscation the title of this talk we
have two titles for the stock you need
to call it lockable obfuscation or maybe
be obfuscation for compute and compare
programs and the reason that we have
these two titles is because this is
based on two concurrent works the first
one and the joint work with rishabh in
print and the second one is work by
Daniel Bix and your go said Ellis so for
the rest of the talk I will be
discussing both of these works together
I won't make distinctions which listing
appeared in which one okay so yeah as I
was saying yeah so over the last five
talks we have seen tremendous progress
and code obfuscation and by now I don't
need to convince you all that
obfuscation is really awesome we can
build a lot of stuff from it and in all
of these talks we saw that if you can
get office keishon for also kids then
and you can do a lot of cryptography and
what's more interesting is that there
has been tremendous progress in our
understanding of the underlying
assumptions for getting office Kishin or
i/o for also
it sound so back in 2013 the first when
we got the first candidate
we had obfuscation based on some exotic
assumptions but there has the remarkable
progress since then and as you saw
yesterday we can now build off the
station on certain assumptions which you
can summarize in one slide okay and
hopefully soon we'll have IO from
standard assumptions and you'll wake up
one morning open a print and you'll see
people with the title io for standard
from standard assumptions and that also
comes up with the consider good prize
money
ah but for now we we need to manage with
L to be plus something else and so now
it's not clear whether we can actually
build office kitchen from just L debris
or standard assumptions so we address
this problem from the other end of of
the line what we try to do is we try to
anchor ourselves to standard assumptions
and then try to ask what for what
functionalities can be based can we get
off the station whose security is based
only on the learning methods problem or
other other standard assumptions so put
more formally I'm interested in the
following question for the rest of the
talk what functions can be obfuscated
using standard assumptions and since
this is a lot of seminar this will be
the standard assumption that we'll use
is lob so this question has has received
a good amount of attention over the last
few years and in particular in fact Ron
Kennedy showed how to get point function
of suspicion for point functions even
before we had the notion of or the
formal definitions of obfuscation and
since then we have had office Kishin
schemes for things like hyperplanes and
conjunctions and in today's talk we'll
see a physician for
a special class of functions called
compute and compare programs
so what is this class of functions so
let me first describe this function
class so in this function class every
function is parametrized by a program P
and a string alpha and the program FP
alpha works as follows it takes as input
some string X it first performs a
computation on this string X now using
the program P so it computes P of X and
then it checks if P of X is equal to
alpha if P of X is equal to alpha then
it outputs one else at output 0
so let's see what we can capture using
this function class first if you set
your your program P to be the identity
function that is it takes any string X
and just outputs X then you can see that
this exactly computes point functions so
recall a point function is a function
which is parameterized by a certain
string alpha it takes an X and it
outputs one if X is equal to alpha and
it outputs zero otherwise and as I just
mentioned if you look at f with identity
as your program and your string alpha
then this is exactly a point function
which is parameterized by
let's make it a bit more interesting
let's look at conjunctions so recall a
conjunction is a the function over n
bits and the function is defined as you
take a subset of those bits and then
compute an and of either the bit or its
negation so in this case for example I
have described this function f which is
x1 + x5 and not of x7
okay
there are multiple ways to define this
program P and string alpha such data are
a compute and compared program captures
this conjunction let me present one way
of doing it so the program P I'll define
it as follows it takes n bits x1 to xn
and just outputs the first and the fifth
and a seventh bit
and I set the string alpha to be equal
to one one zero
so now you can note that this
conjunction F is exactly identical to
the program F which is parameterize by
this P and this ad
so hopefully by now you're comfortable
with this notion of computer and
compared to let me make it a bit more
complicated so let's parameterize the
functions by not by just one string but
by two strings and I'll find a message
the Alpha is used to check whether P of
X is equal to it or not and if it is
equal it output is a message if not at
output C
so so this is the notion feel free to
ask any questions during the talk in
fact let's keep this as interactive as
possible okay
so this is the function class what about
security so as I had mentioned at the
start of the talk we will be looking at
BBB security now in particular we'll be
looking at something called average-case
BBB security and BBB roughly says that
if you give an adversary and obfuscated
code all that the adverse we can learn
is just the input-output functionality
and nothing else and for this special
class of functions there's a much easier
definition and it's as follows
intuitively what you want is if you
choose your string alpha uniformly at
random or from certain distribution then
the office Kishin of P with the string
alpha and the message should hide both
the program P and the message
and this can be captured by a simple
interactive game between a Challenger
and adversity so here's the game the
adversity first sends a program P and
some message the Challenger chooses a
random string alpha and then it either
sends an obfuscation you know the
program P with with alpha and the
message or it sends an obfuscation of
some garbage program
so when I talk about garbage programs
think of it as a program which always
outputs zero
and the goal of the adversary is to
distinguish between these two scenarios
so it should guess whether it got an
office keishon of the program P with
lock alpha and the message or whether it
got an office keishon of a garbage
program
and if you're someone who likes giving
names to cryptographic primitives we
have a name for this primitive we
decided to call it lockable obfuscation
and this is because we are thinking of
this string alpha as a lock it checks
whether P of X is equal to alpha alpha
and then if it is then it allows you to
open the message
okay so for the rest of the talk I'll be
referring to the string alpha at the
lock and I'll be calling this lockable
obfuscation
and
and some of you might have already noted
that this string lock must be long
enough in particular this should come
from some distribution with sufficient
min entropy and why is that because if
not did the adversity can always rain so
let me quickly illustrate
so let's say you had a single [ __ ] lock
then the adverse we could just say and a
program which accepts all inputs and now
if the Challenger chooses this alpha to
be equal to 1 then the adversity can
distinguish because if it receives in
obfuscation of the program P it can run
it on any input X it will get output 1
and if it receives an efficient of
garbage
it will run it on any input it will get
our output 0 so in this way the
adversity can distinguish if your lock
is not longer
you
but thing to note over here is that if
your lock is long enough then if I give
you an office kitchen of a program P
with with a random lock and some message
if you don't if this lock alpha is
independent of your program then even
the honest user will not be able to
evaluate this on any input X so whatever
input X is the honest user tries it will
get it will get zero okay
so as I've described it right now it is
a it is not clear whether this thing can
have any applications or not because
again I want to stress on the fact that
this string alpha that you choose must
be independent of the program P and the
message to get any any sort of security
so in a nutshell if I had to summarize
how we are getting applications out of
this the main idea is that in the honest
setting this lock alpha will be
dependent on the program P but will
first switch it in such a manner such
that it becomes independent and then one
that becomes independent then we can use
the security of lockable obfuscation
so that brings me to our results light
can I can I ask a question so in some
sense you know this is similar in spirit
to you know things like attribute based
interaction and predicate encryption all
these things we're in the security game
there is no functionality or point
office kitchen for that matter with the
random point exact exactly right yeah
thanks we note for the heads up yeah we
will see attribute based encryption
predict encryption and yet this is
actually very related to what he just
pointed out Thanks
okay other questions are there any
questions about the notion I somehow
cannot see the
oh there is a question
why is there no trivial distinction
between office creation of pee and
garbage that's a good point because
because I've chosen this I'm not office
getting the program P I'm office kidding
the program P with a random law of alpha
okay and note that if you run how do you
distinguish what is the trivial
distinction well you run it on some
input but with with a very good
probability if you run it on some input
X then both programs will output 0 so I
hope that answers the question
okay great
so let's see oh by the way I think
whenever I switch to a new slide I think
it shows the number of pages which it
currently shows as 176 but don't be
worried
I promise I'll finish this well before
scheduled time okay so bring in to our
results light be sure how to construct
lockable obfuscation from learning rate
errors and then we show a number of
applications the first class of
applications is what I call upgrading
security and here we have three
applications the first one is making
encryption schemes anonymous this will
be the focus of the talk the next one is
upgrading business encryption to
something called IO for rejected
programs and then finally this is the
application of making secure sketches
private and then we also have a second
class of applications where our goal was
to replace indistinguishability
obfuscation in certain certain
applications with lockable obfuscation
so why is that useful because let's say
you build something from in
distinguished media office Kishin then
we don't have any instantiation of that
based on lwe but now if you replace IO
with lockable obfuscation then you get
that thing from L debris so here we have
two two applications or two classes of
applications the first one is called
circular security separations and the
second one is called random Oracle and
instability results
okay so let me now talk about the first
application which is making encryption
schemes enormous okay so this notion was
introduced by Ballarat all in 2001 and
oh yeah that's a good question so the
question is instead of having one alpha
can we have a list of alphas and yes if
the list is a constant or polynomial
sales you can have you can have this
functionality the cost is that your
program size will all decided
obfuscation will grow with the size of
the list in particular if you have let's
say a sub exponential number of alphas
then you cannot get a polynomial sized
obfuscation
okay so yeah so the first application is
work which I wanted to talk about is a
lockable of is anonymous encryptions
Keynes let's first recall what is an
anonymous encryption scheme so a regular
encryption scheme you have a public key
and an adversity can see an encryption
using public key PK and the guaranty
that we have is is that this adversity
won't be able to figure out anything
about the underlying message okay that
is very useful but let's consider more
general scenario where you have multiple
users each user has his or her own
public key so here you have three users
each one has a public key PK 1 PK 2 and
TK 3 respectively and now let's say I
send an encryption of a message to the
third user so I encrypt my message using
a PK 3 so the adversary's if the
adversary sees this encrypted message it
it does not know what the underlying
message is but maybe it can learn what
that this message is meant for the third
party and in certain situations this can
be dangerous and we want to avoid the
adversity from learning this information
so say
even when it sees our ciphertex it does
not know which public key was used to
encrypt the site
so as I mentioned one of the
applications of our work is to take any
encryption scheme and to make it
anonymous question no it's okay so how
does this work
the first note that here I'll be
thinking of the decryption circuit which
takes two inputs it takes a secret key
and it takes a ciphertext and it uses
the secret key to decrypt the ciphertext
and it outputs a message or a reject
symbol so I'll think of this decryption
as described as a circuit
let's see how how the anonymous
encryption works so I want to encrypt a
message m using a public key PK
and what will I do first I will choose a
random string alpha and then I will
encrypt this string alpha using the
public key PK so note that I have not
used the message that I originally
wanted to encrypt I have instead chosen
a uniformly random string and CT is the
encryption of this random string
and now consider this program P which
has which has this ciphertext CD
hardwired so this takes an input as
input it can take any string and then it
will try to decrypt this ciphertext C T
using that input string in particular if
you take the secret key corresponding to
this public key PK and feed it as an
input to this program P then it will
output alpha this program P will output
alpha
and the last step is to output an
obfuscation of this program P with the
log value alpha and the message M as the
anonymous ciphertext
okay so the the ciphertext is is a
program is an obfuscation of P alpha n
how does decryption work in our
anonymous scheme well you're given a
program and you're given a secret key
what can you do we can just run the
program on this input so this is what
the anonymous decryption does it it
takes this program the program which is
the anonymous ciphertext and then runs
SK on this program
why does this work so recall our program
P is this decryption circuit with the
cipher text CD hardwired so note that if
you look at the secret key so SK is the
secret key corresponding to this public
key PK
and note that if you run this program P
on SK it outputs
alpha
so what does that mean if you think
about the obfuscation if you run the
obfuscation of e alpha and message with
the secret es k then that should output
the message this is the this is the
correctness guarantee of our office
Kaczynski so by the by the correctness
we can argue that if you run the Sigma
run the secret key SK on this office
credit program you should get back em
and this is indeed what we want from a
decryption you want to know if you have
the anonymous ciphertext and you have a
secret key then you should get back
there get back the message
okay any questions about the scheme
No
okay
so next we need to argue that this thing
is indeed secure so recall again this is
what was happening in the anonymous
encryption first you encrypt alpha then
you consider the program P which has the
this ciphertext C T hardwired inside it
and then the obfuscation is the
anonymous cypher text as an obfuscation
of PE with alpha n message
so at this point and one might be
tempted to immediately use lockable
obfuscation but note that you cannot use
lockable obfuscation yet because this
program P is not independent of the lock
value alpha why is that because this
lock value alpha is contained inside
this ciphertext C T and the ciphertext C
T is contained inside the program P so
in particular this program P depends on
the lock value alpha in so we cannot
directly use the security of lockable
obfuscation but we can do something we
can do just one more step and then use
lockable obfuscation anyway so we have
this anonymous ciphertext and so let's
see there's an adversary who claims that
he or she can guess the public key given
this anonymous ciphertext
so now consider a new encryption scheme
where everything has a prime so
encryption and on prime C T Prime and P
Prime so what's happening here instead
of encrypting alpha you now encrypt 0 ok
so CT prime is an encryption of 0 and
then P prime is the decryption circuit
but it has the ciphertext C T Prime
hardwired outside
and finally you give out as your
anonymous ciphertext and on CD Prime and
obfuscation of this program P Prime with
lock value alpha and a message M
okay
so using the security of your encryption
ski-in of the underlying non-anonymous
encryption scheme using the security of
this base encryption scheme you can
argue that these two these two cipher
text will be indistinguishable
okay
so which means if the adversity could
guess the public key from an obfuscation
of P then it should also be able to
guess the public key P key from the
obfuscation of P prime okay so this is
what we have here we have this adversity
who claims that he or she can guess PK
from this office question of P prime
alpha nm and at this point you should
note that your string alpha is
independent of your program P that's
because your program P now only depends
on its on CD prime and CD prime is an
encryption of Z so program P prime is
independent of alpha so now you'll know
what to do you can use the security of
lockable obfuscation to argue that this
are the obfuscation of P prime is
indistinguishable from the obfuscation
of garbage
okay is that a question
okay great so so now we have an office
kitchen of garbage and now because both
these both the previous hybrids were
indistinguishable it means that the
adversity claims that he or she can
guess the public key from this
obfuscation of garbage but this is
clearly impossible because the there is
no information of the public key PK in
this obfuscation of garbage
this concludes our security proof
more questions
you
right but okay so that's a good question
the question is uh in the previous
hybrid we gave the adversity more
information particularly gave the
adversity information of M so in this
question is about this hybrid so but
note that here we are trying to be not
hiding M we are using the encrypt the
NCPA security is over the string alpha
the encryption of alpha versus the
encryption of zero
so yeah so this concludes our proof
overview of how you can use Locker
blocks ascription to make any encryption
scheme anonymous
but anonymous encryption schemes by
themselves are not very not very
interesting in terms of an application
because we already had these things from
from standard assumptions since the very
beginning it gets much more interesting
when you look at more advanced
encryption schemes and it turns out that
you can use the same methodology to even
make advanced encryption schemes
anonymous in particular we can do that
for broadcast encryption and even for
attribute based encryption
so let me now talk about attribute based
encryption since there we're not trying
to hide the public key but we'll be
trying to hide something else first
let's recall what attribute based
encryption is you already heard about
this in wrote in stock on Monday so an
attribute based encryption scheme is a
mechanism to have some more fine-grained
control over your data so here we have
four algorithms a set up encryption key
generation and decryption the set up
outputs a public key and a master secret
key now the public key can be used to
encrypt any message M for certain policy
F okay so the encryption algorithm takes
the public key it takes a message it
takes a policy F and it outputs a
ciphertext
the master secret key can be used to
generate keys for attributes X for any X
you can generate a key for this X and
finally your secret key skx will be able
to decrypt a ciphertext C T only if f of
X is equal to 1 if I perfect they're
equal to zero then this output part
you
so Rotom already told you why this
notion is interesting so the security
what we want to hide so let's say an
adversity has an encryption of a message
M for a policy F and it also has a bunch
of secret keys it has the secret key for
X K X 1 X 2 and so on 2 X cube what do
we want to hide yes totally we want to
hide the message m and this is the is
the most basic notion of activity based
encryption where if f of X I is equal to
f of X K is equal to 0 for all key then
the message M should certainly be hid
however you may ask what about the
function f it need not be hidden so this
is the base notion of attribute based
encryption you might want something
stronger you might want to hide the
function f m and that takes us to the
notion of predicate encryption where if
f of X XK is equal to 0 then the message
M is hidden and the function f is also
hated
and note that here I'm talking about
hiding F even when the adversity can
decrypt the ciphertext so let's say F of
XK is equal to 1 for some K then the
adversity can use SS k xk m m to decrypt
the ciphertext but we're saying that all
that the adversity can learn is just a
message and not the policy f
and would be amazing if you could
achieve this notion unfortunately it
turns out that this already implies
obfuscation so let's settle for
something in between which is sometimes
called as one sided predicate encryption
so here again we want to hide hide the
policy or hide the message em together
with dark we also want to hide the
policy if the if the adversity cannot
decrypt up cannot decrypt the cipher
text in particular if if f of X K is
equal to 0 for all K then both the
function f or the policy F and the
message m are hidden and note that again
if f of X K is equal to 1 for some K
that is if the adverse key can decrypt
some cipher text candidate to the cipher
text using some secret key then we don't
want to hide the policy
but this notion the one-sided predicate
encryption can be interesting and
certain settings however it turns out
it's pretty hard to construct these
things in particular we have a number of
constructions of attribute based
encryption this is just a subset of the
total number of construction that are
out there but if you look at one-sided
predicate encryption we basically have
just the analog of the of the work of
Bnei at all this was shown by gorbunov
we know then how take in 2050
so using lockable obfuscation what we
can do is you can take any of these
schemes on the left
basically just patch it together with
lockable office Kishin in a similar way
as to what I showed in the in the case
of public key encryption and that will
give you a one-sided predicate
encryption for with the same properties
so this is all I want to talk about in
terms of the applications I check if
there are any question
[Music]
okay so now let's let's look at the
construction
construction follows a two steps but
before I talk about the construction I
want to quickly talk about how how this
notion of obfuscation came into being
like the behind the scenes of lockable
obfuscation okay so in my opinion it it
all starts with this book by alison
Susan and Brent where they construct
something called two circular security
separations so this is some some special
encryption scheme where it satisfies in
CPA security but it does not satisfy
something stronger called to circular
security it says so we want to construct
an encryption scheme which satisfies in
CPA but does not satisfy something
stronger so Alison and Susan and Brent
showed a construction based for this
based on l2b
in 2015 following that there was a
construction two concurrent works showed
how to extend this to something called
as n sub P low security separations for
any n and again here we want to
construct an N CPA secure encryption
scheme that is not n circular secure
why do you want to construct these
things well it's mostly out of
theoretical interest and but one other
motivation at this point was that this
was one of those things which we knew
how to build from lockable all from in
distinguished MIDI office Kishin but we
didn't have any construction based on
standard assumptions and this these two
books were the first ones to give
constructions based on Enderby
shortly thereafter a joint work with
rishabh and print we extended this
something called bit circular security
separations and it turned out that under
underlying this bit circular security
separation was already some sort of
obfuscation going on and this
immediately led to the notion of
lockable obfuscation you can answer that
question at the end of the talk that
okay so yeah so this is the
behind-the-scenes story of a lockable
obfuscation let us now look at the
construction so the construction goes in
two steps
the first step is to build lockable
obfuscation for low depth circuits or
nc1 circuits and the second step is to
bootstrap such an obfuscator so we have
let's say we have an obfuscator that can
handle log depth Serkis we combine that
with a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme and that gives us alpha station
for all circuits and note that here we
use fhe schemes with low depth
decryption and you already saw that and
howtechs talked Monday
so let us first look at the second step
which is the bootstrapping step since
this is very similar to the application
descent that I talked about a couple of
minutes ago so again the goal here
you're given an obfuscator for NC 1
you're given an fhe encryption scheme
and here I'll assume that this fhe
encryption scheme is a secret key
encryption scheme that is the encryption
uses secret key the decryption also uses
the same secret key evaluation however
is public there's some evaluation key
and using that evaluation key you can
evaluate any circuit any ciphertext to
you can perform home Orphic evaluations
on a circuit so given these two tools we
want to construct office Kishin of a
circuit see this this circuit c can be
of arbitrary depth and we want to office
keep this with lock alpha
okay
let's see how to do that the first step
is to use your fhe encryption scheme to
encrypt the circuit see so you have some
canonical description of this circuit
see we use a fhe to compute an
encryption of this circuit see
and then we need to use a prosecutor so
here's what we love this kid
so consider a program P which is the
decryption circuit with FK hardwired so
this program takes as input a cipher
text and the program decrypt the cipher
text using the secret key SK and outputs
the decryption so we will use our nc-1
obfuscator to obfuscate this program
with lock alpha
and again why can we do this because
this decryption is the fhe decryption
which can be done in NC one
so first let us see whether this gives
us correctness so we have these two
components the first one is an
encryption of the circuit the second one
is an obfuscation of this program we
want correctness correctness basically
means if if you we want to be able to
evaluate this program such that if C of
X is equal to alpha then this evaluation
should output one
so let me first describe what this
evaluation is so you have the
homomorphic you have the ciphertext what
you can do is you can homomorphic
evaluate on that ciphertext to get an
encryption of C of X so given an in
given an input X I can define a
universal circuit with X hardwired and
then I can perform a homo fake
evaluation on the ciphertext with the
universal circuit and that will give me
an encryption of an encryption of C of X
good so now note that if you feed this
encryption of C of X into this program
which are
decrypts using SK then you should get
back C of X okay and in particular if C
of X is equal to alpha you'll get back
alpha so if you run this ciphertext on
this of the skeeted program then it
district nurse of our office Kishin
scheme this should output 1 if C of X is
equal to alpha and it should output 0
so this shows that correctness holds
what about security
note that we want to say that this
encryption of the circuit C does not
reveal the circuit C because that is
what you want to hide we want to hide
this okay C but you cannot just argue
that immediately because this ticker key
SK is also used in this obfuscation
but you had note that the lock value
alpha is independent of the circuit
which is a decryption circuit so you can
replace that with an obfuscation of
garbage using the security of your
obfuscator
and once you do that this there's no
information about this secret KSK in the
obfuscated program so you can safely
replace the of the encryption of C with
an encryption of garbage at which point
there's no information about the the
socket C in in the final our hybrid
so using these two steps you can argue
that this office kitchen indeed hides
the circuit see a couple of questions
[Music]
you
how complex is this a morphic evaluation
yeah so good question this homomorphic
evaluation is not much more complicated
than the circuit evaluation in
particular if you have a circuit of
certain size and certain tip the
universal circuit that runs on this will
also be of similar size except with
certain logarithmic blow-up and yeah
I'll take the the other question about a
be too one-sided predicate encryption at
the end of the talk okay
great arm so this is how bootstrapping
works so let us now get to the the
lattice fun part of the stock which is
constructing lockable obfuscation for NC
1 based on the learning material
function so recall this is what we want
we want to obfuscate this circuit C with
a lock value alpha and this so could see
outputs let's say M bits the first
natural step is to decompose this
circuit C as M boolean circuit so each
of these circuits C 1 to C M takes a
certain number of inputs and outputs
just a single bit so now we want to
obfuscate these M circuits C 1 to C em
together with the lock alpha
and from Malaya stock we know what to do
with whenever we see a boolean circuit
of log dip we know what to do with it
you just express it as a branching
program so let's say you have this
circuit C tilde
you can express this I'll take questions
in a minute so you can express C tilde
as a permutation branching program of
certain length L where the length of the
branching program is roughly exponential
in the depth of your circuit C tilde but
since C tilde has a logarithmic depth
the length of this branching program is
polynomial so each of these are matrices
B IB is a five by five matrix and how do
you evaluate this so on any input X you
basically choose one matrix from each
column perform a product of those of
those matrices and we have the guarantee
that the product is either equal to
identity or some fixed permutation
matrix so in particular if C tilde of X
is equal to one then we have the
guarantee that you know product of BJ XJ
is equal to some permutation matrix
which I'll call P accepting and if C
tilde of X is equal to zero then the
product of these are these permutation
matrices is the identity matrix
and for simplicity in this talk I will
assume P this accepting permutation P
except has the following form it has
basically permutes the first in the
second position but keeps the others the
same so I take a couple of questions at
this point okay this is also related to
the application attribute based
attribute hiding and so I take this at
the end of the clock okay so again
yeah recall this is what we have we have
this branching program you take a subset
product the subset product is equal to
this accepting permutation or the
identity
so now we want we have these em
branching programs be p12 BPM we have
this lock value alpha and we want to
office key T such that for security the
obfuscation hides all branching programs
BPI and for any X if you evaluate
reevaluate the branching program each of
the branching programs on X and the
evaluation matches alpha sub I for all I
then our office kita should output
output Y
you
question where is the message message oh
very good question so here I am talking
about a simpler case where there's no
message it just outputs 0 1 but this
same construction can be extended to
hundred messages good point yeah thanks
for bringing that up ok so this is what
we want and so now I present a
three-step recipe for obfuscating these
M branching programs together with a
lock value alpha how do you do that
the first step is to choose a bunch of
random matrices subject to the
constraint that the summation m I alpha
I is equal to 0 so this is very easy
what you can do is you can choose to M
minus 1 under matrices and set the last
one depending on your constraint so this
is very simple
the next step is to encode each
branching program BPI together with
these two matrices mi 0 and mi 1
so first this encoding must hide this
branching program PPI and secondly the
evaluation of the encoding it should be
possible to evaluate the i8 encoding on
any input X and this evaluation should
output either mi 0 or mi 1 depending on
whether you are branching program
accepts X or not
so this is what I want from the from the
encoding
so as some of you may have already
noticed that these two goals are
somewhat contradictory because if you
can evaluate on any input X and get M
sub y 0 or I 1 that certainly leaks some
information about the branching program
PPI in particular if for example it can
tell you whether there are two different
inputs lead to the same output or not
so to relax that I will make my a goal
slightly easier what I'll do is I'll ask
for
I don't want n sub I 0 M sub I 1
but I'm ok with some matrix R sub x
times mi 0 mi 1 and this matrix R sub X
is derived from Diarra under means that
he used during a recording and another
thing to note here is that this matrix R
sub X does not depend on the index I
this is not a typo this is by design we
want this matrix R sub X to be
independent of your index I and this
will be crucial for our correctness and
finally once you have all of these MN
coatings you just output all the N codex
so the first step the third step are
pretty easy the second step is where all
the action is happening
okay so again so let's see how how this
correctness works we have these two
guarantees we have that the summation mi
alpha I is equal to zero and then we
also have that the evaluation of the
encoding on string X gives you r sub x
times mi 0 ni 1
what you can do is you can evaluate each
of these encoding sir on input X so as
we know that in yet encoding takes you
to R sub x times mi 0 or mi 1 and then
what you do is you can add up all of
these terms sum them up from I equals 0
y equals 1 to M and the evaluation
outputs 1 if the sum is small
why does this work because let's check
if if let's say the branching program
evaluation matches the string alpha at
all positions but then this thing is
nothing but R sub x times mi alpha I and
then if you sum them all up
note that this thing does not R sub X
does not depend on your index I you can
take that out and once you take that out
this sum is equal to 0 so if this is 0
then these are close there now even this
thing must be small
so this is our yeah this is how
correctness works so which means that
since the first step and the third step
were pretty simple it suffices to just
focus on our this encoding of the
branching program VP together with these
two matrices m0 and m1 so note that I
have now gotten rid of the indices I
from here because we just focus on one
party program
so why does this help it looks like this
goal is not very different from what we
started off with but these matrices and
permutation matrices are really friendly
object and as you saw in your let's talk
just an hour ago you can use the GG H 15
encoding to take care of this in
particular recall what he'll a talked
about so if you have some secret
matrices s 1 and s 2 you can encode them
into matrices D 1 and D 2 such that they
satisfy this relation that a 0 times D 1
times 52 is equal to or it's close to s
1 times s 2 times a 2
and you can use this for also again you
lay talked about this you can use this
for taking subsets products so let's say
you have four secret matrices si 0 SI 1
RS 1 0 2 0 1 1 - 1 you have a matrix a 2
and on the right you have a 0 and di
beep
as Gilad described you if you take any
subset on the left multiply it with a 2
it's roughly close to multiplying a 0
with the same subset on the right you
can do this for multiple subsets so
here's what we'll do
now we'll take the branching program
which has all of these permutation
matrices will encode each matrix into
ggh 15 secrets so how do we do that
so first recall this is what we have we
have the product of BI excise is equal
to either this accepting permutation or
this identity matrix now let's say I
multiply this on the right with a vector
z 0 z 1 and some land of stuff what do
you get you get you either get Z 1 Z 0
random stuff or you get Z 0 Z 1 random
stuff the thing to note here is that the
first entry of this product is either
equal to Z Z 1 or Z 0 in particular the
branching program at sets X this this
the first entry is equal to Z 1 if it
does not accept X the first entry is
equal to 0 so this is close to what we
were what we wanted except we wanted to
do this with matrices so what do you
want to do what do you do when you want
to get this behavior for matrices well
you just multiply or your tensor
everything with identity so now in a
similar way if you look at the product
of BI excite answered with the identity
and then you look at the first block of
this of this product times M 0 M 1 and
some random stuff then you either get M
1 or M 0 if depending on whether the
branching program accepts X or not so it
looks like this thing should help us at
least get our functionality working in
particular what we'll do is we'll set
our GG 8:15 secrets to be these matrices
s S sub I X I is nothing but b IX i
tensor with identic
okay and then once we have the g15
secrets we know how to go o to encoding
so recall this is what we did in the
last talk these and bi B matrices are
just AI minus 1 inverse of the secret
that you want to encode together with
some noise and finally I will be giving
an encoding of m0 m1 and some random
stuff I just output a 2 inverse of M 0 M
1 N and perfected
so we want to first check that this
evaluation on X indeed gives us m0 m1
depending on what behavior you want and
this is easy to check again you use the
subset product methodology to to note
that okay so note that we have this
relation that say s2 + 0 x as - 1 x a2
is close to a zero times d-10 times e2 1
so now you multiply on the right of both
of these with a 2 inverse of m0 m1 and
some random stuff and because these are
these matrices a 2 inverse are small
these two products are still close to
each other ok and note that what we have
on the left is nothing but this product
of SI x i's times this m0 m1 vector and
then if you look at the first block of
this you either get M 1 or M 0 okay good
which means this evaluation works but
what about security that does this
encoding hide the I at branching program
unfortunately not because we are
certainly revealing the final output so
that leak some information about BPI how
do you fix this it's pretty simple
instead of encoding bi this bi be tensor
with identity you just answer instead of
the identity you replace with some
random loan or matrix
this is the summary of of our
construction we first encode these
blunting program matrices into these
into these GZ 815 secrets where each of
these is a bi B times some naught times
10 surd with some loan or matrix and
once you have these GJ 15 secrets you
can encode them using digit 15 and and
you also give out a 0 and a 2 inverse of
m0 m1 and brackets now the question is
is this thing secure and at this point I
will before I get in security I'll look
at the questions okay there's a question
why is a inverse small and this is
because we are not talking about the
traditional matrix inverse but rather
this is the inverse that's computed
using a lattice trap those so Shwetha
talked about it in the first first
bootcamp book cheb and even Yeley I
talked about this in the previous talk
all of these matrices a 2 inverse are
are not matrix R is this is not equal to
a 2 inverse times this vector B but
instead this is a this is computed using
something known as lattice grab those
and that guarantees that this thing is a
short ok but this is our linkage just a
heads-up there's like 5 minutes left
yeah that's great yeah thanks ok so what
do we want we want to argue that if m0
and m1 are random then the distribution
on the top looks like the distribution
in the bottom where we replace all of
these di B's with some random loner
matrices
and how do we do this the step is to use
now the gpv result which says that if
you look at a inverse of a uniformly
random thing then that is
indistinguishable from a random low norm
thing in particular note that these m0
m1 and all of these vectors are all of
these matrices are uniformly random so
you can say that a 2 inverse of this
random thing looks like a lone or matrix
which is here
so we have this now and we have our
encoding D to B which is a 1 inverse of
something now we want to argue that
these D to B matrices also look like
short lone or matrices
and the way to do that is we'll first
replace this thing inside a 1 inverse
with something that's totally random and
in order to do that we need something
known as a permutation ldbe which was
introduced by a Canadian chain and what
this is a variant of L to be if it says
if you take any permutation matrix P and
you look at the following two
distributions the first distribution is
you output a random matrix a together
with peat answered with R times a plus
noise where this R is a random lonar
matrix then what this result says that
this distribution looks like two
uniformly random matrices
so I'll illustrate why this works using
a quick example so let's say you take
this this permutation matrix and tensor
R and now we want to see what this
matrix times a looks like so you can
decompose this matrix a as a 1 a 2 a 3
and a 4 and then check that this product
is indeed r r times a 3 r times a 4r
times a 1 and r times a 2 now if you add
some noise to each of these terms then
you can use a traditional lwe to argue
that each of these is indistinguishable
from uniformly random
and another important thing to argue
here or to note here is that this only
works a permutation matrices in
particular if you have this non
permutation matrix then clearly this
this does not if this thing is not
looking like a uniformly random matrix
okay so we are close to the end first we
switch this matrix with a random thing
using this permutation Elda beam
mechanism and then we can replace this
using GPB to random loner okay so once
you do that for D 2 0 and d 2 1 you can
do the same for d 1 0 d 1 1 and if you
have more levels you can keep doing this
cool so this is what we wanted this was
our three-step recipe ok and I'll be
done mm-hmm I wish I had more time to
let you think about this but
unfortunately we not done yet because
this requires these matrices mi 0 and M
i1 to be uniformly random and these
matrices are not uniformly random
because they are constrained by this
constraint at the top
and how do we take care of this well if
the number of magical grams then this M
value was large this was a much larger
than some polynomial in the input length
and the branching program length then
you can use leftover hash lemma what if
not what if you had let's say our
shrinking circuit so the easy fix to
that is to take some injective PRG put
the PRG on the top and now your lock
value becomes equal to PR g of alpha
how you handle this sense once you do
this then you're done and this concludes
our construction you might be tempted to
ask well we could not handle permutation
branching programs here how do you do
that before that you have to read a
follow-up book by Allah and others where
they had an interesting approach to fix
this
these encoding why does this look like
random loan on well you have to listen
to Rashad's talk for that and yeah so
this is just almost and almost goes to
the last slide ok so this is what we
should follow up works are shown a
number of other applications rich app
we'll talk about this thing called mixed
function encryption there also been
interesting applications for just zero
knowledge some immediate open questions
first I feel there should be more
applications over here so this is
something to look into second
interesting question is whether you can
allow some sort of leakage on the
auxiliary information now or some
what happens if you output the lock
together with your physician and finally
says I I did not describe what or
evasive so good sir but this thing is a
subclass of invasive circuits can we get
off listen for other invasive circuits
that would be interesting
so finally ah we are almost at the end
so this is Lily talked about these
different views of GTH 15 I want to
conclude with that so so know that this
is what we had so we have these two
circular security separations and we
have GD 15 and both can be seen as some
sort of in being inspired by Jesus w13
homomorphic encryption we derived this n
secular security based on the to secular
security around the same time we kind of
those should how to obfuscate
conjunction based on the GG 815 route
then we showed how to get bit circular
security gilja and Ron showed how but
construct a private constraint PRS from
ggh 15 and then finally we had lockable
obfuscation in hindsight it turns out
that all of these things can be
instantiated using G th 15 but I feel
the some fun and doing all of these
things directly and yeah I'll conclude
my talk at this thanks so much for your
attention